one of the cruelest aspects of mental
illness is that it strips us of any
ability to believe that other people
might be suffering in the way we are
we aren't being willfully egocentric or
arrogant
we are condemned by our illness to a
feeling that we are uniquely pitiful
uniquely unacceptable uniquely awful
the central legacy of mental illness and
a major contributor to our suicidal
impulses
is a feeling of exceptionalism we start
to run away from other people
gatherings become impossible for we grow
preemptively terrified of the presumed
invulnerability
and judgmentalness of those we might
meet we can't possibly make small talk
or concentrate on what someone else is
saying when our heads are filled with
catastrophic scenarios
and an intrusive voice is telling us
that we should die
there seems no compact or acceptable way
to share with old friends what we have
been going
through they knew us as chatty and
optimistic
what would they make of the tortured
characters we have become
we start to assume that no one on earth
could possibly know
let alone accept what it is like to be
us
this is especially tragic because the
central cure for mental illness is
company
our disease denies us access to
precisely what we need most in order to
get better
in 1891 the swiss artist ferdinand
hodler
exhibited the disappointed souls five
figures are pictured in varied states of
dejection
we don't know quite what has gone wrong
in their lives but hodless talent
invites us to imagine possibilities
a marriage here a social disgrace there
a depression
a feeling of overwhelming anxiety
however awful the individual stories
might be
the true horror of the painting emerges
from the way each crisis is unfolding
in complete isolation from its neighbors
the disconsolate figures are only
millimeters away from one another
but they might as well be in other
countries it should be so
easy to reach out to share the burden to
lend a comforting hand
to swap stories and it would be so
life-giving
but no fellowship seems possible in this
insular hell
sadness has wrapped each sufferer up in
a pitiless sense of their own
singularity
hodler wasn't painting any one scene he
intended his work as an allegory of
modern society as a whole
with its absence of community its lonely
cities and its alienating technologies
but in this very depiction lies the
possibility of redemption
we will start to heal when we realize
that we are in fact always
extremely close to someone who is as
wretched as we are we should hence be
able to reach out to a similarly broken
neighbor
and lament in unison we should learn to
come together for a very particular kind
of social occasion
whose whole focus would be an exchange
of notes on the misery
and lacerations of existence in an ideal
gathering of the unwell
in a comfortable safe room we would take
it in turns to reveal to one another the
torments in our minds
each of us would detail the latest
challenges we'd hear of how others are
going through sleepless nights
we're unable to eat we're too terrified
to go outside
we're hearing voices and had to fight
against constant impulses to kill
themselves
the material would be dark no doubt but
to hear it would be a bomb for our
stricken lonely souls
ideally we would keep meeting the same
people week after week
so that our lives would grow entwined
with theirs and we could exchange mutual
support as we traveled through the
valleys of sickness
we would know who was in particular
difficulty who needed tenderness and who
might benefit from an ordinary sounding
chat about the garden
or the weather it isn't possible that we
are as alone as we currently feel
biology doesn't produce complete
one-offs there are fellow creatures
among the seven billion of our species
they are there but we have lost all
confidence in our right to find them
we feel isolated not because we are so
but because we are unwell
we should dare to believe that a fellow
disappointed soul
is right now sitting next to us on the
bench waiting for us to make a sign
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most
important and often neglected areas of
life
such as finding a good enough partner
and mastering the art of confidence
click now to learn more